hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game uh that comes as a
suggestion from a subscriber peter
merozzi so thank you for suggesting this
one it's not so much about the game as
about the gentleman who created the game
as the game is a fabrication
as far as i understood it but i will
link an article in the description below
so you guys can check it out so uh the
thing is uh you all know what the uh elo
system is when you win a chess game you
earn some elo you can check out elo of
other players there's a top 100 list in
the world there's a top 100 women's list
in the world there's top 100 juniors
and ilu is just a very very important
way uh
for us to understand who is uh
who is uh how good in chess for example
magnus is over 2800 so that means he's
uh
extremely good in chess and there are of
course players who are 2700 2600 to 2000
1500 1400 1000 so
there are um you know a variety of
strengths of course regarding this
however uh it is attributed to the arpa
elo who did not as i understand it
create this system the system was
created by none other than roger cook of
sydney
who died this week at the age of uh at
the age of 80 years old and
this article was published in the sydney
morning herald and it was sent to me to
check it out so the game
is uh basically a fabrication of uh
roger roger cook and he uses his
pseudonym jim sumtner uh who he
sometimes used to to create fun games um
such as this one and this one is
specifically
really awesome as it features seven
queens on the board which is with with
perfect play or even with reasonably you
know good play
he will not be seeing seven queens on
the board however this game is quite
believable uh as you'll see so
interestingly uh when cook uh
started using his elo rating list uh we
uh kind of got a got a glimpse of how
good someone was but it was not uh
sort of uh how good someone was over the
course of 10 years but how strong he is
at the moment so that's uh that's why uh
the the uh we call it the elo rating
list but it would seem that it's the
cook's rating list uh although by the
time that feeder requested um arpadillo
if they could implement it in the in the
video rating system for chess uh
everyone was already calling it uh an
elo system so that's why the uh elo name
uh name stuck around uh but
interestingly uh even though uh
we we don't use cook's name when he uh
first implemented the let's say the the
past two years of tournaments uh in the
world uh in 1966
which was kind of the the bobby fischer
era bobby fischer was only second on the
undefeated alice the first was actually
viktor korchnoy yeah so
i don't know how how precise he was or
you know how
uh how
um thorough he was at uh
filling out the the games but i imagine
he was very thorough and it would seem
that viktor korchnoy was the was the
highest rated under on the first video
rating list uh but okay i just wanted
you guys to know that because i did not
know this and uh well roger cook seems
to be a very very important person for
for for everyone playing chess so i
thought you guys would be interested in
knowing this uh but this game here like
i said it's a fabrication and it's the
one that was created uh in sydney in
1965 by uh roger cook or
as uh
here you can see jim sumter his pseudo
name uh so let's check it out and why
it's so uh so crazy with the seven
queens on the board so here the opening
is perfectly normal and something that
you would see every day if you play the
sicilian or if you like playing against
the sicilian so e4 c5 we have knight to
f3 knight to c6 and now d4 so a nice
open sicilian we have captures captures
and now e6 going for the timeline of
variation knights to c3 and queen c7 the
bastrop variation we have bishop to e2
uh a6 now taking away that b6 b5 square
from the knights we have castles and
pawn to b5 we have king to h1 and now
knight to f6 uh we have f4 and now uh if
you've ever had similar positions you
always spend a lot of time especially if
it's a classical game calculating if
your opponent can push b4 or not because
if your opponent can push b4 you're just
gonna lose the e4 pawn which is not
something that you want to do but here
black goes for b4 it's not the best move
uh but okay this is where where the fun
starts and the white of course if just
moves the knight then white loses this
pawn so here white plays e5 with b
captures in c3 grabbing the knight and
white also captures the knight on f6 we
have c captures on b2 f captures on g7 b
captures on a1 promoting his pawn to a
queen and white does the same g captures
on h8 promoting his pawn to a queen and
now how do we continue queen captures an
a2 we have queen captures on h7 now if
this was a real game uh why i said that
it's very unlikely that you would see so
many queens on the board there are many
many great moves here for white like
knight captures here like f5 like bishop
to h5 those are all great moves but okay
uh here queen captures on h7 was played
and now both players start pushing the
other pawn for the queen we have a5 h4
uh a4 h5 we have a3 and h6 now both
players move the queen queen to b1 we
have queen to g8 and now pawn to a2 we
have pawn to h7 a1 promoting to a queen
and pawn the h8 promoting to a queen so
we are at move 20 and there are already
six queens on the board now it doesn't
matter how good you are uh it's
impossible to calculate uh what's
happening here uh following four queens
on the board is difficult enough six
queens that's uh i mean that's that's
just silly uh so here we have queen to
b4 defending the bishop on f8 as white
was threatening to pick it up bishop to
e3 offering a queen trade here and now
knight captures on d4 first we have
bishop counter on d4 now attacking the
queen offering a trade again and black
declines uh mr king plays queen eight to
a3
we have bishop to h5 now finally putting
pressure on this diagonal and now d5 now
the queen also helps out with the
defense of the f7 pawn f5 trying to bust
open the position and now bishop to a6
attacking the rook on f1 f captures on
e6 opening up the position and here mr
king just castles queen side
uh rook captures on f7 attacking the
black queen here and now queen c to a5
uh bishop to e7 and it's still a very
interesting game but after queen to a5
there's just not all that much for black
to do however uh this is uh like we said
a fabrication and we need more queens
than the board c3 attacking the queen on
b4 queen to d6 and now bishop to g4
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries so if e7 then okay you lose
too much material so here rook to e8 was
played but now just pawn to e7 with
check we have king to b8 and now e
captures an f8 bringing a fourth queen
into the game for white uh and the
seventh queen in total yeah and in this
uh sort of fabricated game it was in
this position on move 30 that uh mr king
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here but just uh i'll
show you what would happen uh i mean
look at all this firepower attacking the
rook here let's say you take one queen
of the board it doesn't really matter
queen captures an f8 queen captures rook
captures and that's it now you're
getting checkmated not much for you to
do here you're gonna deliver a check now
yeah the king has to go back somewhere
on the on the sixth rank king to c6
queen to e8 with check and now after
king d6 is just a nice mate in one queen
to d7 with the check or queen the e6
would check or you know you can pretty
much do anything and still win the game
but yeah in on move 30 after he captures
on a faith promoting to a queen and mr
king resigned and what uh what a
wonderful game uh finishing uh with a
position of seven queens on the board so
really really incredible but uh not as
incredible as the revelation at least
for me that it was not arpadillo who uh
invented the elo system but it was
actually roger cook
so i was very very happy to find out
this new information for me so hopefully
you guys are happy as well uh that
you've learned something new regarding
chess uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it and uh hopefully you
guys were also wearing a hoodie uh
during this video to honor uh both of
the hoodie guys uh i would like to thank
the first elden lord nagarjuna ponogoti
congrats harry three grads andre theron
and alexander john huart for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the chess
world the norway chess blitz starts
today and then of course the norway
chess classical event
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day